I should've become a producer at
BuzzFeed hi I'm Darren Carter I'm a
stand-up comedian hi I'm Michele
Stevenson and I'm also a stand-up
comedian what's up I'm Grant Cotter I'm
a stand-up comedian and today we are
playing and never have I ever
comedy and it goes Lincoln we're gonna
play that never have I ever been booed
off stage don't drink
trust me don't think that's the problem
I'll be like DJ turn the microphone up
driving out these boos who said that
never have I ever been hit on after the
show every night baby get with it look
at the state hello
that's how I met every single wife I'm
unlike this one come on man it was
actually the most corniest thing I've
ever seen any it hit me because he could
like I went comedian and it just did
some time he got really comfortable he
dropped a sugar packet in front of me he
goes hey you dropped her nametag never
have I ever bombed during my comedy set
duh you have to bomb to get good Oh
bullsh just look at that he's lying
you're gonna comedian if you happen
that's the truth please I mean yeah
never have I ever lost my cool on stage
not yet what yeah
Kentucky maybe you want to listen to my
show so I went and did the rest
half-hour in Spanish they had to knock
out a comedian for over laughing at my
show oh I had actually gwad punch this
monkey everyone's laughing and he
overlap and it just me tough cause he
kept doing it I said you know what you
lose someone and I want to write on the
audience and punch this mother and got
back on the stage and the audience left
I was like oh you're going to laugh
either never have I ever taken a joke
too far yeah but I took the joke too far
on stage and the audience revolted
against me so I'm not about to elaborate
on what I say on the Internet where I
could just get eaten alive in the
comments oh so I have I was doing this
Mexican bar and what ended up happening
is I didn't know this if you tease the
audience that will get a paper a white
piece of paper and and send it to you
that means get the hell out they're
gonna see you after the show
I have not I'm gonna go all the way and
don't get never have I ever made someone
from the audience cry I have I have I
have people last 24 tears that come out
there was a beautiful death
it wasn't the guy you punched cuz he was
laughing too hard not he won and he said
the most gangsters were there I'm gonna
sue you
never have I ever wanted to quit comedy
every day baby I should have become a
producer at BuzzFeed I have everyday I
don't because there's no other job I can
do but yeah I wanted to go I have not
I'm married to it I'm full I never have
I ever received unsolicited nude pics
unsolicited no I've never been that
lucky never just woken up to like an
email full of pigs I do a lot of things
in my dance
really what no I'd yeah yeah but mostly
kids I'm a nurse too so like they'll be
like this is a rash and I'm like it's
only seven inches away from thinking you
are the doctors I'm not a dermatologist
one time a woman sent me something and I
didn't know what it was I want to send
me is a picture of his lips I had to
have my wife come in and take a look at
[Laughter]
never have I ever lost stage time to
another comic then we are a lot of times
it's like a big star I remember even
when I back when I first got here to
Hollywood Rodney Dangerfield came into
the club and it was great and what was
great is he only did 10 minutes so it's
like he actually by him going up there
going okay and he had like it was trying
out jokes and you know I get no respect
Oh Rose who you know the crowd was
Rodney Dangerfield so they stuck it
actually helped and they also helped
that he did ten minutes he didn't do
like two hours or something never have I
ever been rejected due to my nationality
or gender I'm gonna say I have not I
have I have this is I was showcasing for
show called CTV CBC or mocha see from
which case yes that was a network and
they told me not your two Mexican for
this network but get CTV never have I
ever said someone else's joke on stage
Penza no no I have I have I learned my
lesson when I did take another comedian
joke I was a year into the game didn't
understand anything about it
I've got booked to do a show I was
supposed to do 20 minutes I only had 7
minutes and I did the comics jokes and I
learned a lesson because every person
that left the show kept telling me how
funny that guild was thought to myself I
didn't get those laughs he did so I
learned day one out the gate I say I
never do that so I took that joke I said
I don't have a problem with it never
have I ever had to perform stand-up
comedy for free I have like I just
started getting paid I mean my first
couple years I would drive from here
Arizona for it yes look people want
different hours people would say you get
a dinner in 20 bucks I knew I was gonna
get the dinner I didn't know if I was
gonna get the 20 bucks never have I ever
been heckled on stage get heckled all
the time one time a woman tried to stab
me with her wine glass because I was
talking to Kobe Bryant I was like I
don't even like sports get over it I
love I can't wait to get Hecker
sometimes but it's very rare that I get
one but when I do I have I have and it's
hard when it's your own dad
[Music]